i'm batman
hello there issue number four of
batman's adventures on the fortnite
island has arrived
and like usual we're going to break it
down and find all the secrets easter
eggs
and important law you need to know i'll
link the series if you need a catch up
and if you'd be so kind to drop a like
and maybe
just maybe think about using code
adamaru lots of things to get through
today so sit your butt down for 10
minutes and let's jump into issue 4
of batman fortnite
zero point
so batman finally escaped the loop at
the end of the last issue but
immediately was faced with a bad dude
he's known for many years deathstroke
holding catwoman hostage
deathstroke is trying to take charge of
the situation right away but batman
quickly realizes he can speak again
his first words after leaving the loop
are all right
let her go very cool as the standoff
continues look at what catwoman is doing
another hand gesture if you're into
heavy metal you know this is something
ozzy osbourne throws up
but in the world of sign language this
hand gesture means ily
or i love you this brings bats and cats
into action as they overpower their
attacker deathstroke
after taking a foot to the face he yells
wait
this isn't necessary and then i'm not
your enemy
of course the spandex duo don't believe
him but to prove his innocence
deathstroke surrenders this is quite a
monumental thing for deathstroke to do
he hasn't done this to batman ever
before
to explain his actions deathstroke state
that most people are hostile when they
first leave the loop
in terms of law this does make sense we
could use the npcs stuck halfway in the
loop and halfway out
with those exclamation marks over their
head always destined to fight
out of nowhere batman's memories come
flooding back
every single loop he's been through is
now remembered
hundreds if not thousands of rounds of
battle royale
so he can now remember the loops and he
has his voice back
but there's one more issue nobody can
remember what happened before they
entered the loop
all knowledge of gotham city is gone
batman can't even remember
the time he danced like no one was
watching
victory
batman and catwoman decide if trusting
deathstroke is a good idea
a harpoon joins the party and diam
selena
then we get the reveal six people have
escaped the loop before deathstroke
they all converge on the newcomers now
let's test your knowledge
can you identify the former loopers we
have the eternal voyager from the season
x battle pass
hang on i said season x season x is here
and the world is destabilizing
fast that's better we also have bandalet
from season eight which was back in
march 2019
we have bonehead from season two chapter
two that's back in april 2020
magnus from season five what a great
season that was who is now a giant
amongst men
he joined battle royale in july 2018
and then we have renegade raider who is
from season one of fortnite
september 2017. do you feel old yet
and of course there's fish sticks who
joined the party in season seven
on december 27 2018. now let's talk
about this gal what's up guys
me renegade waiter renegade raider has
been here the longest
escaping the loop in 2017 so she's the
unofficial leader of the group
due to her longevity let's be honest
this group is on the edge of tearing
each other apart
as they retain the memories of being
eliminated hundreds of times by one
another back in the loop
bats and cats agree to join the group
and raider takes batman on a tour of the
island in her four years here raider has
tried
everything to escape but it all was
futile
she attempted to row past the barriers
of the island but only the void was
waiting there
this is how aeronauts met his demise
away from the island reality and gravity
seems to be nothing but the void raider
continues to break down the things she's
seen over the last four years
including the meteor showers from back
in season four of chapter one
and more recently the device event from
chapter 2 season 2.
they've already figured out that the
device event was created by
highly intelligent beings with vast
resources
and get this raider states a structure
on the small island in the lake
it was just there one day just like it
was for us
and to bring the story back up to
present day she tells us that the
mechanical structure suddenly became a
tower
which we see this season so she's
telling us that those events
are related i looked back at the device
event and the primal map
and although the main erection is in the
same place the struts don't match up
mainly as there was five that came out
of the water that day
and there's six on the primal map things
don't line up perfectly but i think we
all agree that the two versions of the
center island structure
are far too similar to be a coincidence
[Music]
renegade wader reveals an artifact she
found years ago
a stone tablet with some sort of ritual
drawn upon it
she deduces that god-like beings at the
bottom here
are taking people like us to the island
without their knowledge
each location or world is different
judging by the people brought out of the
loop
they include different biologies and
technologies like a fish man
and and whatever this is a face only a
mother could love
this rock actually ties up with many
ritual sites in the game right now
ever walked past one of these and maybe
harvested them for rock
this season we've seen more than usual
with offerings to the gods by them
could these runes symbolize something
let's check back
batman takes over because that's what
batman does bandalet though stands her
ground
shouting hold on just a minute why
should we listen to you
and this is the next panel no words are
stated
just a stare i think we all know why we
should listen to batman
because of batman i'm batman i'm batman
i'm batman i'm batman i'm batman the
group agreed to follow batman's idea and
split up to search the island for more
clues
bruce chooses selena to be his partner
of course he does because in private he
wants to talk to her
and figure out how they know each other
in the real world
were they friends enemies co-workers
maybe even husband
and wife this kitty is a little forward
to say the least
no a few days pass and the survivors
regroup
they find artifacts on the island which
demonstrate this place has been around a
great deal longer than we first thought
including civilizations unseen for
millennia
the conversation turned to an escape
plan rifts are ruled out and bonehead
confirms the group has even tried
breaking open the contained zero point
they failed but i bet it was fun to
watch them pickaxing it like this
options were running out until the
hatches
those things we've stared at for years
looking for answers
well they finally have a use magnus
demonstrates how indestructible they are
but batman ain't got no time for that
he's got 200 iq
science brain after whipping out his
tool batman begins using energy
frequencies found around the island
to attempt to open the hatch so here's a
question can you remember where the
hatches are
in game right now there's three i
believe the first is here on a single
island in the north hidden under a shack
the second is in the sea on the west
side of the island just by one of these
questionable ritual sites and the third
is hidden under a bush to the right
of retail row batman sends the team to
gather energy signals from anywhere they
can reach
fish sticks is super op here due to his
ability to breathe
underwater and deathstroke proves he's
useful too
by scanning the center spire and guess
what
that is the very signal they needed
batman opens the hatch
whoa hold on for a second daddy oh
before the squad go down there let's
figure out how the signal worked
how did a primal erection open the
sacred bunker
let's go back a little to understand
at the start of the season when the
spire was created do you remember the
method
the foundation sealed himself and the
zero point in
to prevent this reality from collapsing
this could be the energy signal
deathstroke captured
but i believe the thing which is pivotal
here is this
the portal device agent jones used this
is the way he controlled the loop from
within the loop
and we think it's iotec because that's
his former employer
who more than likely use the hatches to
change the island when we aren't looking
it all fits together long story short if
agent jones didn't summon the foundation
batman would never have opened the
hatches batman stops the tribe from
rushing into the bunker and
instead asks fish sticks to search for
underwater traps
and off he pops the rest venture into
the unknown
at the foot of the stairs awaits a brand
new enemy type we haven't seen before
huge stone creatures come to life to
prevent them from advancing batman goes
big brain like he always does and
figures out the runes on their heads
are their weak spots and they take them
out well that was pretty easy
simples hang on nobody says simples
anymore do they
sorry anyway did these guys remind you
of the og rock family from chapter one
those guys were so wholesome as the team
wandered through the abandoned caves a
weapons room is seen
with equipment for days pickaxes helms
and even
a pink minigun gg's on the colour choice
there fortnight
after separating into pairs batman hears
something under the rubble
using his super ability of old man
hearing
under the rocks it's fish sticks and
he's dying
i was actually a little gutted to see
the orange guy taken down
i also felt i'd seen this pose before in
a batman story
and remembered death in the family did
you ever read that run
well spoilers batman dies in that in a
very similar pose
and very similar markings now i'm doubly
sad with his dying breath
fish sticks hands a device to batsy a
transponder of sorts
and now things get funky the device
could let someone access the loop
without losing their memories
by the way fishstix is still alive and
milking this death scene like he's sean
bean
but he does get the best monologue of
the story so far someone is lying
they didn't escape the loop they were
never in it they remember
everything one of us is working for
and then he dies perfect timing bro
thank you the final shot
of the issue sees batman reiterate this
point one of us
is working for them to be continued
i really enjoyed that issue full of law
we learned about the first loopers to
escape
we found out the hatches have a purpose
and potentially the ritual sites are
part of something bigger too
but one of the team is a fake a phony
who's your money on it looks like it's
trying to set up deathstroke as the
double crosser
but i'm not too sure what do you think
who is the double agent potentially
working for io
i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
next time for issue five we're so close
to the end now
thanks for sticking around to the end
much appreciated hey look legends on
screen
oh that one's a legend and that one oh
that one's a mega legend
yeah and that one there legend that one
is just just a legend
complete legend [ __ ] the hola see ya
[Music]
you